NARRATOR: It's not
really about the hunting.
It's just being out
in the woods, and seeing the
different species of animals.
Just being out there alone.
The serenity.
Just discovering new
things and looking at
just how nature acts.
(screams)
NARRATOR: Palm Beach
County, Florida.
Home to the JW Corbett
Wildlife Management area.
Nestled between West
Palm Beach and Lake
Okeechobee,
lies over 60,000 acres
of protected forests
and wetlands.
Known as the Old Florida
Tangle, this preserve hosts
a diverse array of wildlife.
From deer and Bobcats to
water fowl and reptiles.
A rich bounty that attracts
the most passionate
outdoor enthusiasts.
People like James and Terisa
Boyce who've been hunting
here for over 15 years.
JAMES: I've been hunting
since I was five years old.
I started out when I was
a young fella in Maine.
And my father took me in the
woods and with my brothers
learned how to hunt.
And from thereon,
I moved to Florida.
And I carried on
hunting to this day.
TERISA: The first time I
actually went officially
'hunting' James took me
and you know we walked
through the woods together
and I got to see like
a deer in the wild.
Flash forward 16 years
later, and we're still
doing the same thing.
I'm still following
him around the woods.
(laughs)
I've learned so much
about the animals and
what they can provide.
And the different
nutritional values.
So it's been like the
field to table process.
JAMES: We have never ate
anything from the store
in ten years for meat.
We only eat off the land.
NARRATOR: It's the
beginning of the season.
And James and Terisa
are hoping to get
their first deer.
JAMES: That morning,
November 9th, 2019, was
like any other morning.
It's first day of hunting.
And was just supposed
to be a normal,
regular hunting day.
TERISA: So, we arrive
at our location.
And then we lock the
truck up, grab our gear.
So, it's cloudy, it's
kind of gross looking.
A little drizzle.
JAMES: So, we went
by trail three.
Trail three goes all the
way from the top of Corbett
down to the backside.
And around. The first
day of hunting
is when everybody gets
in the woods to hunt.
And there's so many
people, in swamp
buggies and shooting.
And so we knew that
buggies hunt from the
Main Road to trail three.
So, what do they do? They
scare all the deer that way.
NARRATOR: James and Terisa
continue down Trail three
hoping to intercept
the deer being scared
off by other hunters
in the area.
JAMES: By that time
it was probably around
8.30, quarter to nine.
We get about three miles.
TERISA: We're navigating
through the water
and the rain is starting
to rain a little harder.
My feet are getting soaked.
I'm getting soaked. And
at this point it was
chilly. And I'm miserable.
I'm just, I'm done. I'm
like let's just go back.
JAMES: And I said you
know, you're right.
It is started to rain a
little harder. Let's go.
TERISA: So, now we're in
headed back to the car mode.
So, you're not really
paying as much attention.
And I was just trying
to keep up with him.
JAMES: She was trailing
behind, ten to 15 feet.
And I remember her
saying what she wanted
to eat for breakfast.
And I was like yeah
that sounds good.
I step around a Palmetto
bush and all of a sudden
it felt like I stepped
right into an electrical
outlet. Like a jolt.
And all of a sudden
my leg's numb.
And I like how did
electrical get out here,
three miles in the woods?
TERISA: And then I
heard him scream.
(screams)
TERISA: I'm thinking
he got bit by a snake.
That was my first thought.
Oh my gosh, it's a snake.
JAMES: And I look down
and I got a gator with my
whole leg in his mouth.
NARRATOR: The American
Alligator evolved over
a 150 million years.
Around since the time
of the dinosaurs.
Found in fresh water rivers,
swamps and marshes across the
south eastern United States,
this large semi-aquatic
reptile can grow up to
15 feet long
and weigh over 1800
pounds making them
one of the fiercest
predators in the region.
Dr Marisa Tellez, Executive
Director of the Crocodile
Research Coalition,
has been studying these
animals for years.
And she knows exactly
what James is up against.
MARISA: The American
Alligator have evolved
a bite force to clamp
down and to hold on.
A ten foot alligator,
you're looking at a
bite force of about
1800 pounds per square inch.
That would be like a
semi truck falling on
your big toe.
JAMES: All I remember
saying 'you gotta be
(bleep) kidding me.'
And of course now he's
crunching down
and I am telling you the
pain, if you go one to
ten it had to be a 15.
Enough to make your eyes
roll back in your head.
And I'm screaming, like
I was being murdered.
(screams)
TERISA: I've never heard
him scream that way.
I know something is wrong.
This is not I've hit my
thumb with a hammer
scream. This is bad.
And I just freeze.
I'm processing.
What just happened?
What's wrong?
JAMES: It happened so quick
and he was not letting go.
I'm in a fight now.
TERISA: What's the matter?
JAMES: She didn't
know I'm in a fight.
I didn't have time
to tell her that.
I'm getting bit by a
gator. Hold on honey,
be right there.
I didn't, no. I yelled
at Tes to stay away.
Stay back. Stay back.
The reason why she was
not an experienced hunter.
And she's not that
good of a shot.
But the number one
reason I'm afraid
there's a nest there.
And I did not want
her getting bit.
NARRATOR: But James' fear of
an alligator nest is unfounded
this late in the fall.
MARISA: During this time
of the year it's past
alligator nesting season.
It's not that momma
alligator is protecting
her babies.
She's now pretty much
left the nest and those baby
alligators are by themselves.
It's very possible that the
Palmetto bush was able to
hide possibly the prey
that this alligator may
have been protecting.
JAMES: When he didn't want
let go, I knew he wanted
that leg.
And he's crushing it and I
hear popping and popping.
He severed all the
nerves in my leg.
That's what the
electricity shock was.
It was from all the
nerves he severed.
So, he hit me hard enough
to rip the nerves the
first bite.
And now he's getting
into the bone.
He just slowly crush.
It was like a vice.
Then I'm on his tongue.
And he's like ah.
And he let out
the growl is there
his eyes are there
looking right up at me.
And then he's like just
scooting back with me like.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
And I have this gun
on my shoulder.
But now I'm fighting with
him and grabbing the gun.
And I started hitting him.
Hitting him to enough
where that gun started
breaking apart.
I hit him in the nose. I
hit him on top of the head.
I hit him in the
eye a few times.
At the time I didn't think
it was doing anything
because he was just going
back and forth, it didn't
make a difference.
And course I've got
blood now running
down in his mouth.
When your whole leg is inside
an animal, you are becoming
part of the food chain.
Here I am eating the
food that God's created
and taken off this earth.
Now I'm becoming his prey.
He was looking at
me as a food source.
To be eaten alive.
OLIVIA: I was aware
that they were in
the United States.
I know they've been
moving up through
Brazil over the years.
Part of some crazy
experiment.
Nature can be treacherous.
I never in my life
thought that I would
live to tell about it.
NARRATOR: Orlando, Florida.
It's mild winters and sub
tropical climate
make it not just a popular
vacation destination.
But also a great spot for
professionals to gather
for conferences and
corporate retreats.
Which is why Dr Olivia
Affuso and Dr Daheia
Barr-Anderson have come here
to attend an annual sports
medicine conference.
OLIVIA: I'm Olivia Affuso.
And I'm an Associate
Professor of Epidemiology
at the University of
Alabama at Birmingham.
I'm very passionate about
spending time outside.
And that has actually
contributed to my work
in physical activity
with women.
NARRATOR: It was through her
work with women in fitness
that Olivia built her
friendship with Daheia.
OLIVIA: I've known
Daheia for, I don't know,
maybe 15 years or so.
DAHEIA: And I can't
remember when we first
started talking
and we started
becoming friends.
But when we did we found out
that we had a lot in common.
OLIVIA: We bond over you
know engaging in physical
activity with women.
I'm more of a runner and she
really is an expert in yoga.
DAHEIA: Then we started
being roommates at our
ACSM annual meetings.
And so we would always see
each other and reconnect
at least once a year.
NARRATOR: In May 2019, Olivia
and Daheia meet up again
for the American College
of Sports Medicines
annual conference,
along with 6,000 other sports
medicine practitioners.
OLIVIA: It's myself
and Daheia and her
mentoree, Scott.
DAHEIA: It's the end
of May in Orlando and so
the weather is beautiful.
OLIVIA: Tropical kind of
climate environment with
lots of trees
and plants and flowers.
NARRATOR: After a long
day of meetings, they head
out for a casual dinner.
OLIVIA: So, as we were
walking to dinner, I see two
guys that are on a boom lift.
It appeared that the
two guys were
changing the signs,
like those banner signs
that you would see in front
of a convention center
about whatever
event is going on.
At first nothing seems
out of the ordinary.
Until I notice them
sort of flailing.
And then the screaming
starts.
(screams)
DAHEIA: We all hear the
workers screaming and we
look over
and we see that they are
kind of surrounded by
this swarm of bees.
OLIVIA: The swarm of
bees just came out like a
mushroom cloud around them.
I've never seen
that many bees.
And they were immediately
attacking the two guys
that were on the lift.
And of course, they
were screaming.
(screams)
NARRATOR: As Olivia and
her friends look on, the
workers furiously try
to protect themselves
from the swarm of bees.
But their efforts
seem futile.
DAHEIA: You could hear the
terror in their voice.
OLIVIA: It was horrific.
The screaming.
DAHEIA: There had to
be thousands of bees.
It was like an opaque
mass, like of a cloud.
NARRATOR: The Honeybee.
A small winged insect
known for its unique
social organization
and honey production.
The most common bee, the
Western Honeybee, can
live in hives of 80,000.
They play a crucial
role in pollination
and the female bees can
deliver a painful
venomous sting
from a tiny barb
on their lower abdomen.
Dr Juliana Rangel, associate
professor of apiculture at
Texas A&M University
has been studying
honeybees since 2001.
JULIANA: Honeybees
are insects in the
order Hymenoptera.
They are cousins
to ants and wasps.
Probably what Olivia
is observing is a
big honeybee swarm.
A honeybee colony is
considered a super organism.
A higher level entity that
lives together as one unit.
So, when a worker is going
to sting as a defense
mechanism,
that is the ultimate way
in which they defend
they colony.
And of course they
die upon stinging.
So when they sting, that's
it, they lose their life
and they're willing to do so
for the good of their colony.
OLIVIA: They were
very aggressive.
They appeared to have
been resting along
the side of the pole.
And when the guys were
trying to change the sign,
they probably just moved
the sign that was there.
And I think they
disturbed the bees.
They just descended
from that pole
and completely covered
the guys within a
matter of seconds.
And I knew that they
were in trouble.
JULIANA: When the lift
workers are peeling
off the banner,
they are making the
bees aggravated
because they feel that
they need to defend their
resting site.
And that's when the whole
swarming and defensive
behavior starts.
When a colony is ready to
reproduce, it issues a swarm.
Which is a smaller unit
of bees with a queen that
stops in a temporary place.
They're defending
that resting place.
They feel threatened,
they think that they're
probably gonna get eaten
or taken somewhere. And so
they are definitely
enacting their defensive
behavior to take care
of the queen and the
rest of the colony.
(screams)
(simultaneous dialogue)
DAHEIA: Anyone who knows me
knows that I went bonkers.
Cause we had two very
different reactions.
And I started backing away
and going over to the left,
as far away from
the bees as I can.
Olivia, she runs
towards the two guys.
OLIVIA: I knew that I had
to do something because if
they did not get help quick,
they were going to die.
I know there's a limit to
how many stings you can
sustain before you die.
And so, I had to move
as quickly as possible to
try to get them some help.
To try to get them out
of the swarm of bees.
JULIANA: These bees
definitely seem to be
more aggressive
than the normal,
gentle honeybee.
Which leads me to suspect
that they come from a
specific lineage of bees
that is more aggressive
in general than others.
OLIVIA: I was like I
have to do something.
And so, I noticed the
police car on the
side of the street
and I just immediately
ran for help.
I just tapped on the window
and I'm like you have to
call an ambulance right now.
We gotta get those guys down.
We gotta get them down.
And then I turn around and
I run back over to the left.
The guy is trying
to use the controls to
come down from the lift.
As the lift is coming
down, I can see that they are
completely covered with bees.
Even though they have their
shirts over their heads,
the bees are still attacking
them through their shirts.
And on their hands
and just everywhere.
And they are screaming
bloody murder.
Help! Help!
NARRATOR: According to venom
scientist, Christie Wilcox,
the pain caused by
venom is by design.
CHRISTINE: Bee venoms primary
purpose is to cause pain.
So, once you've been
stung by a bee, there is
a gland full of venom
and that whole system
actually rips out of the bee
and stays inside of you.
And that muscle that pumps
the venom will keep pumping,
sticking more and more
venom through that
needle into your body.
So, one bee sting tends
to be fairly harmless.
When you have hundreds
upon hundreds of bee
stings,
all of a sudden you are
talking about a very
different dose of venom.
The danger when you
have hundreds and
hundreds of stings,
is that you have
this massive release
of histamine.
And that can cause your
throat to close, your
heart to stop.
All sorts of very life
threatening things.
OLIVIA: I could see
that there was a fire
extinguisher.
And I said to myself I
have to be able to do
something with that.
As I try to get the fire
extinguisher I'm immediately
covered by bees.
They were stinging
my head, my arms, my
hands, my legs, my feet.
Probably upwards of
100 stings.
I was just on fire.
JAMES: And when I looked
at his mouth open,
my foot was down in it,
and his mouth was past
my knee. I knew there
was a problem.
A major one because he
started pulling me back
and trying to do a roll.
MARISA: The death roll
is very famous amongst
crocodillians
in regards of
dismembering prey.
So, an alligator would
latch on to a piece of prey.
And the force of the
death roll, it actually
just comes from the snout.
And the force generated from
the current of the snout,
it allows the alligator
to dismember prey
that is much larger than
the alligator itself.
But it's not just about
dismembering or in a sense
taking chunks out of prey.
But they'll also use it as
a way to injure an opponent
so that they could get away
or possibly win a fight.
JAMES: (screams).
TERISA: He's
screaming very loud.
He's making a blood
curdling scream.
JAMES: Stay back.
TERISA: Get back.
I'm telling you get back.
What happened?
What's wrong?
JAMES: I rolled with him
twice. It felt like hours.
But it wasn't, it was
only a few minutes.
And then hit him
again, he left go.
And that was my break.
It was like oh.
I knew it was bad cause
I could just feel the
warmth of the blood
running down my
leg into my boot.
And the right side of
my leg I couldn't feel.
Well I knew if I did
not tourniquet my
leg I'm a dead man.
So, I turned around
and ripped my belt
off, dropped my gun
and started tightening
up my leg.
And he came running up
from behind me and grabbed
me on the back of the leg.
A second time. Now I
can't see him. That
was my mistake.
Should never have
turned my back.
MARISA: Turning your
back to a predator is
a submissive position.
And so, that alligator
likely came back for
him just to say
I have weakened my opponent.
My opponent is submissive
but I'm gonna go one more
time to let him know
that I am the winner in
this particular battle.
JAMES: Then when he did
that I said that's it.
I'm just gonna shoot him
and I was gonna either
blow my leg off
or blow him away with my
leg in it. I didn't care.
NARRATOR: In an effort
to kill the alligator and
minimize damage to this leg,
James shoves the gun barrel
as far into the alligator's
mouth as he can.
JAMES: I stuck the
barrel inside his mouth
and all of a sudden he
let go and he took off.
MARISA: James using
his rifle
and pounding against
the back of the throat,
most likely made the
alligator release.
In the back of a crocodilians
throat, is a sensitive area
called the palatal valve.
It prevents water from
going in while swimming
around or hunting.
The alligators would
definitely not want that
to be damaged because
that would impact its
ability to be able to
successfully hunt,
especially under water when
it's trying to catch fish
trying to catch turtles.
TERISA: He's backing up
to get out of that area
and then he's telling me
give me your belt. I
need your belt.
And I'm dumping the gear.
I'm throwing my rifle down.
I'm getting this belt.
And then he's tying the
belt around his leg.
And he's like call 911.
JAMES: Call 911.
And she knew it was bad cause
she heard me screaming.
And she just lost it.
I had to grab her,
snap her out of it and
say you have to gotta
pay attention
or I'm gonna lose
my life here.
Get on that phone. Please.
TERISA: I can't.
(breathes heavily).
I made a couple of
attempts to get 911.
I couldn't.
The cell service
there was very spotty.
JAMES: And she goes there's
no signal. I said I know.
Just keep calling.
Keep calling.
I was in a cypress area
covered with trees, a
canopy of trees.
I'm not getting
out like that.
But there is no
open area either.
And I knew I had to get to
where we could be spotted.
That was my number one.
TERISA: So we start
walking and b-line it
through the water.
JAMES: When we're walking
she's calling and calling.
We get the signal,
lose signal.
And it's spotty cause we're
on the Martin County line
and Palm Beach County line.
TERISA: I was scared
cause now the water
is up to my knees
and it was pouring into
my boots and I know
what's in this water.
There is the alligators
and there's rattle snakes
and water moccasins.
Things that'll get you.
And he's bleeding.
So, when you're bleeding and
there are hungry animals,
the chances are higher
that something else is
now gonna happen.
NARRATOR: Back in Orlando,
Dr Olivia Affuso tries to
save two workers
being attacked by an
aggressive swarm of bees.
She grabs a fire
extinguisher to spray
the bees off the men.
But now she's under attack.
And the pain is intense.
OLIVIA: So, I've
been stung before.
So, it's kind of like
you know going to get
a needle at the doctor.
But now imagine hundreds
of needles at once.
And I just focused my mind
and stay on the task at hand.
I couldn't leave them.
And I got it out.
And I took the fire
extinguisher,
I pulled the pin and I
turned it on the guys,
trying to spray them so
that they could escape
from the bees
to be able to get out.
JULIANA: When Olivia grabbed
that fire extinguisher
what she didn't know is that
she was doing something
similar to the effects
of the smoke created that
we use in bee keeping.
What the smoke is doing
is dissipating the release
of the alarm pheromone.
So, it's calming the bees
down and it's confusing them
because it is mixing
the smell of the smoke
with the smell of the
alarm pheromone.
Only she didn't know
that this was only a
temporary fix.
OLIVIA: And then I ran away
from the bucket, turned
around, closed my eyes.
DAHEIA: She turns the fire
extinguisher on herself
and sprays herself in
the face and all over.
And it was just a blur.
It's a blur of like all
of this that's going on.
OLIVIA: And then I dropped
fire extinguisher right
there on the sidewalk
and I run to the
convention center.
And that's when my friend,
Daheia came to save me.
And she starts swatting
my head to get the bees
off of me.
DAHEIA: I just start trying
to fan them away and I know
I'm smacking her in the head.
Bees are getting angrier and
angrier because we're hitting
them and swatting them.
JULIANA: That actually
aggravates the bees more.
Fast movements and high
contrasts of movements
actually gets them very
aggravated and they want
to sting at a faster rate.
DAHEIA: They're still
swarming around.
My thought is we have to get
these bees off of Olivia and
we need to get out of here.
NARRATOR: After surviving
an alligator attack, James
Boyce and his wife, Terisa,
struggle through the dense
growth of the JW Corbett
Wildlife Preserve.
James, losing blood
rapidly, is too weak
to go any further.
TERISA: Finally I
get through to 911.
I'm JW Corbett.
My husband has got bit
really bad on the leg
by an alligator.
And because we're on
the border line of these
two management areas,
they're two different
counties.
And I was afraid because it
took so long to get through.
Please don't transfer me.
911 DISPATCHER: Hang
one one second ma'am.
Are you in Dupuis or Corbett?
Cause those are two
different counties.
TERISA: I'm in Corbett.
911 DISPATCHER: Okay.
Alright, stay on the
line, I gotta transfer
you to Palm Beach County.
Stay on the line,
don't hang up.
TERISA: You cannot,
please don't transfer me.
I'm like can I just get
anybody, somebody to
come and help us.
NARRATOR: After a few
minutes Terisa is finally
able to relay
their approximate location.
Operators immediately
dispatch a helicopter
rescue.
TERISA: The 911 operator
wanted me to look and
verify the amount of blood.
And he asked me to lift his
leg up, elevate his leg.
I pick up his leg to put
it up over my knees
and the blood just starts
pouring out of his boot.
And I'm like this is bad.
JAMES: I looked down at
my leg and I could see
bone and fat.
And veins and blood
just squirting out.
TERISA: And then he looks
at me and he goes this is
it, you know that right?
So, he's saying
goodbye to me.
And he's talking to me. And
I'm not listening.
I refused.
I wasn't gonna let him
die. I just wasn't.
JAMES: I know my wife. And
I'd see at the back of her
mind, through her eyes.
She kept telling me
I wasn't gonna die.
But she thought I was.
And I knew too.
I thought so too.
Because I do have
a blood condition.
And it's hemochromatosis.
It's very rare.
The blood count on your
platelets is major.
And mine normally is
at 110. Persons normal
is 275, 350.
So, if I lose a lot of
blood, my body can't
make it up.
And she's on the phone.
People couldn't find us.
We'd lose him and I
said to hell with it.
I said get on the phone,
ring and call all the boys.
I just wanted to make
sure everybody knew
how much I loved them.
Cause it gets real. And
if you got anything to
say, say it now.
I called, I think it was
Christopher, and I said look
man, I got bit by a gator.
And he thought I was joking.
I said shut up and listen.
I don't know what's
gonna happen.
I said I love you, I said my
goodbyes to him. I gotta go.
Call the next one.
TERISA: The kids is hard
for me. He says I love you.
I'm proud of you.
You're gonna grow up to be
a great person. I want you
to live your life.
I want you to do the
things you wanna do.
And then he's done.
JAMES: And once I got that
out, the rest is easy.
And I mean you're already
going out because you're
passing out.
You're losing all your blood.
There's no help in sight.
So, you got that working
for you and you just
say well I'm just tired.
You accept it and I did.
100 percent.
Said I'm gonna accept
the death. I was
ready to go then.
NARRATOR: Am ambulance
takes the lift workers
to the hospital.
But Olivia is left with
over 100 stings from
her rescue effort.
Her friends, Daheia and
Scott, are able to get
her into the safety
of the convention center.
OLIVIA: I sat down in a
chair to wait on
medical assistance.
I start to look
down at my arm
and I just can see all
of these little stingers
on my arm.
And we start picking them
out, at least immediate ones
that they see in my face
and on my arm.
Because you know the
bees had stung me here
in my face.
And there were
stingers still there.
JULIANA: When Daheia goes
and plucks the stingers out,
that in theory is a good
idea depending on how
quickly you're doing it.
Because it takes about 20 to
30 seconds for the full
contents of the venom gland
to be injected
into the flesh.
Depending on how long
Daheia took to get rid
of the stingers,
it may or may not
have helped.
OLIVIA: And now that the
adrenalin was starting to come
down from what I had done,
then the pain started
to come with it.
I just felt burning.
After you know the stingers
were removed I just
felt like I was on fire.
DAHEIA: Her skin isn't
really dark right,
and so you could see the
redness starting to appear
on her arms and on her neck.
But she wasn't complaining.
She wasn't yelling. She
wasn't moaning.
And so I think we all
underestimated how
much in pain she was.
And how urgent she
needed care.
OLIVIA: And my blood
pressure started
climbing really high.
And I've never had high
blood pressure in my life.
TERISA: This is serious
now. I'm scared.
He's laying down.
He's done.
And then I hear a helicopter
and I get up and I'm looking.
And here it comes.
And it's going
and it's circling.
And it looks like it's coming
and I'm screaming, here.
It turns. And it goes
the other way.
I'm on with 911 and I'm
telling him tell them
to turn around.
Tell him to turn around,
tell him to come back.
He went the wrong way.
Tell him to bang a left.
I'm heartbroken.
That was our last chance.
JAMES: It was like looking
for a needle in a haystack.
I don't care, you
could have orange,
you can have a lightning rod,
you can have what you want.
They can't find you.
TERISA: So my husband
says we should shoot
shots into the ground.
Somebody could hear us. So,
I put the shells in the gun.
(gunshots)
JAMES: She was firing
it like a champ.
TERISA: And I'm screaming help.
Help.
TERISA: (shouts) Somebody.
(Cries) Help me.
Here comes the
helicopter again.
I'm like okay, maybe
they'll see us.
(Shouts) Over here.
Over here.
As the helicopter's coming
here comes the swamp buggy.
NARRATOR: Terisa's gun shots
alert fellow hunters, Danny
McCullen and his family.
TERISA: And I'm just
like, thank god.
Just thank god there's somebody
here, there's somebody here.
And the lady that was with
them came right to me.
And she just grabbed me.
And I just, I fell
to the ground.
So, Danny runs back to his
buggy and grabs some zip ties.
Our tourniquet just,
it was wet.
It was stretched,
it wasn't holding.
They just zip tie his leg.
JAMES: Woke up to Danny
McCullen and his family
zip tying my legs with
the EZ Zip Ties.
They use them out there
for tying up kegs.
It didn't stop it.
Instead of squirting
out six inches it's just
running down my leg now.
Cause I was losing
so much blood.
I started getting shivers.
I was going into shock.
TERISA: So, we're going
through the woods
and I'm holding my hand
and trying not to get
hit by the trees.
And I'm just praying.
NARRATOR: Finally they
reach a clearing where
a helicopter can land.
JAMES: Course I'm
passing in and out.
Felt like a long ride
to the helicopter.
We got in it, it was
raining, it's windy.
I remember going up and
I said you know what?
Looked at my wife and said you
know if I don't die here I'm
gonna die in this helicopter.
Pilot was like this
is bad weather.
And I'm like yeah, this is
it. And if we're gonna die.
This is meant to be.
NARRATOR: As Olivia
suffers the effects of
a 100 plus bee stings,
outside the convention
center, the swarm of
bees attacks.
OLIVIA: There were tons of
other people coming from
the conference as well
and they were stung. And,
many of them ran into the
building with us.
DAHEIA: It was insane.
One lady she was walking
through and the bees
attacked her.
And so, she you know
is trying to fan them.
And so, she runs
try to get indoors.
And there's a lot going on.
(ambulance sirens)
NARRATOR: EMT's
quickly arrive.
But with the chaos going on
around her, Olivia must wait
to receive medical attention.
DAHEIA: You got the security
guard who's saying I'm
having difficulty breathing.
And then you have the
other lady who says
I'm allergic to bees.
I could die from a
bee sting.
And so, she wasn't
triaged first right?
They were dealing
with the other two.
OLIVIA: I was the one that
sustained the most stings
but they were attending
to other people.
And I understand that
but every time the wave
of fire came to me,
I became a less
understanding.
I just had to endure.
JULIANA: When a bee
stings a person,
she can either have an
allergic reaction or a
toxic reaction.
The allergic reaction is the
one that most people have,
which is localized swelling,
a little bit of pain,
redness around the area.
And potentially can
last for a few days.
For some people one or a few
stings of a honeybee can
cause a toxic reaction
that can lead to
anaphylactic shock.
DAHEIA: And then they
started with Olivia
and they hooked her up.
We had to take her pulse and
check her blood pressure.
And her blood pressure
was really high.
The upper like 150's,
over 90. It was really,
really high.
It started to dawn on me I
think at that point in time,
she was in a lot of pain.
NARRATOR: Requiring
additional medical aid,
Olivia is rushed to
the nearest hospital.
OLIVIA: I am still on fire.
My head is killing me.
I'm in extreme pain.
I'm hyperventilating. My
blood pressure is going up.
And I'm just wanting
something for this pain.
I felt like I was
going to die.
OLIVIA: I felt something
crawling in my hair.
And I'm like is there
a bee in my hair?
So, I reach up there and
I feel something moving.
So, then I grabbed that part
of my hair and I hold it.
And I throw it to the floor.
And sure enough there was a
bee and it was still alive.
The assistant quickly
used one of those little
cups, specimen cups.
And he grabs it and twists
it and he runs out with it.
And he's showing all the
people at the nurses station.
Eventually the nurse comes
in and she hooks up the IV.
She has the three different
combinations of medication.
And she's going to
administer them.
One is like Benadryl.
Another is like an
anti-inflammatory.
That's good.
And then the third one
is a stomach medication
that they use as a
secondary anti-histamine.
As soon as she injects
that I started vomiting
everywhere.
And I couldn't believe that
I had anything to vomit.
Remember I never
made it to dinner.
NARRATOR: After the
medication, Olivia
is discharged
and walks back to the
hotel with Daheia.
DAHEIA: The next day right,
she's an Epidemiologist,
and we're investigators.
And so she wanted to
investigate the scene.
And so she goes back.
She was walking around
with the bee that was
taken out of her hair.
OLIVIA: I run into the other
person who had been stung.
And she said to me one
of the exhibitors is a
beekeeper.
Who is very familiar
with the bees.
DAHEIA: And so, she
pulls it out and the guy
identifies it for her.
OLIVIA: And he said those
were Africanized killer bees.
JULIANA: Based on
all of these facts,
the fact that there were
so many stings happening
at the same time,
the fact that there was a
very high amount of alarm
pheromone being released,
and a very wide active space,
leads me to believe that
these bees were Africanized.
NARRATOR: Africanized
honeybees often called
killer bees,
are a hybrid of European
and African descent.
Bred in Brazil to increase
honey production,
the Africanized honeybee
is known to be more
aggressively defensive.
And has caused over
a 1,000 human deaths.
JULIANA: If you are unlucky
enough to get one of these
aggressive swarms of bees
riled up, what you need to
do is run as fast as you
can and seek shelter.
Unfortunately what
happened to these
workers was unavoidable
because they were unable to
move from the boom and the
bees will continue to sting.
There are a few stinging
deaths every year.
Most likely because a
person was unable to move.
What Olivia did was
heroic and she helped save
the lives of two people.
DAHEIA: I probably won't
run towards danger unless
I know I can do something.
If I'm ever in a
dangerous situation,
when I am not equipped to
do something about it,
then I'm with someone
who is equipped.
OLIVIA: The main thing I
learned from this whole
experience is that
I am far stronger than
I probably give myself
credit for.
And probably also it
confirms that I really do
have a high pain tolerance.
NARRATOR: Back in Palm beach,
James Boyce fights to survive
the 45 minute flight
to the hospital.
Paramedics give medication
for the pain but the wounds
to his leg are extensive.
JAMES: It was mangled. It
was just a mangled piece
of meat.
All of this water
getting to it,
dirty water and infection
and it's just hanging.
TERISA: From the time he was
bit to the time we arrived
and they got him
into the trauma room, it
was close to three hours.
JAMES: And they had the
team of doctors and nurses.
They cut all my clothes off.
The doctor himself, he stuck
his four fingers in that hole.
To see how deep it went.
And they would disappear.
And I screamed in pain.
He like give that man a
shot of morphine.
Let's get him into surgery.
NARRATOR: Because of
James' hemochromatosis,
he's at a much higher risk
for severe complications.
A normal platelet count
ranges from 275 to 350.
James' is dangerously low.
JAMES: And he looked at the
blood work as down to 50.
If you're down to 45,
40, you start bleeding
out of every orifice.
Your nose, your eyes,
your mouth. Then you die.
And it was getting
to that point.
TERISA: I get in the door.
I'm greeted with the
Sheriff's department
and the game wardens.
They have a gator now
that's bitten a human.
In most instances they
have to remove that
animal from the wild.
It's now considered
even more dangerous
than it already is.
And by the time I get
into the room they're
wheeling him out.
So I never truly knew
how bad it was until they
pulled him out of surgery.
NARRATOR: Despite the
extensive damage to his leg,
it could have been
a lot worse.
JAMES: The boot did save
my leg. And it was made
for snakes.
Snake proof.
When he bit on top of
my leg, he bit high,
just enough where he covered
the top of that boot too.
When he let go he ripped
the top of the boot.
And then he got the
bottom of the boot too.
But if it wasn't for that
kevlar boot, he would have
had 100 percent control
of that leg and I
would have lost it.
And it's definitely
saved me the second bite.
Cause the second bite
he got the back of my
leg where the calf was.
MARISA: So, if you're
going out hunting, let's
say out in the swamps.
One it is good to have
another person with you.
So, James's wife
was ten feet behind.
It's possible if she
was closer to James,
this attack may not
have happened because the
alligator's like oh no,
two against one, mm-mm,
not gonna happen.
The other thing that James
could have done is if there
was a long stick, a long pole,
is just to kind of poke
around in front of him.
So, if he did scare
something, something's
gonna lash at the pole
and not necessarily
lash at his leg.
TERISA: I almost
lost my husband.
And I almost lost the
father of my kids.
They need him.
JAMES: People ask well
you know were you scared
of dying? No, I wasn't.
It's funny how you
make peace real quick.
And you start really
thinking about you
know your family.
And family's really
what you got.
And it made me and my wife a
lot closer, that's for sure.
TERISA: I knew James is
really good under pressure.
I just didn't ever
know how good.
JAMES: She was stronger
than I thought she would be.
That's the truth.
So it was a test. That
was a test on both sides.
But she faired
well apparently.
I mean we're both out.
You know we're both alive.
And so kudos I guess.
NARRATOR: Ten days
after James gets the all
clear from his doctors,
with some help from his
sons, he is back out hunting.
But this time he's better
prepared and much more
aware of the dangers.
JAMES: My take away
on this, if you're gonna go
hunting in any area, swamp,
make sure you know
what's in there.
Don't always expect them to
be in the same spot or even
in the same environment.
Come prepared for the
worst day of your life.
That will save your life.
OLIVIA: I think the whole
situation with the bees is
just a product of nature.
We have to be adaptable
the same way that the bees
are trying to be adaptable.
And so they just happened
to stop on that pole.
The guys just happened
to not see them.
And disturbed them and so,
I don't blame the bees.
I just felt really
sorry for the guys who
stumbled into them.
And were stung relentlessly.
But I'm also very grateful
that they survived
and I'm grateful that
I could have offered
whatever assistant that I was
able to on that day.